find someone who has a life that you
want and figure out how they got it I
sort of planned on having a more normal
life just doing something else and then
when I was 18 I moved to New York and
just started singing at the open mic
nights I'm always willing to put the
foot work in like with the mixing if it
takes eight months I will mix for eight
months
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from singer and model Lana Del Rey
and my take on her top ten rules a
success rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well enjoy
finding your own path is not for the
faint of heart it's the harder path it's
easier to just like keep doing the same
over and over again and then be
surprised to when like it's still the
same need the same result somehow that's
easier than just doing something
different I mean I never feel like I'm
like not where I'm supposed to be you
know because I think no matter who I'm
with I'm always still doing my own thing
like I can't remember the last time I
was like in a club or somewhere and felt
like man I'm not supposed to be here and
same with you know or like being in a
theatre or like you know we saw saw Pink
Floyd the other day so I mean I just and
I've kind of been doing it for so long I
feel like everybody I'm friends with
everyone I know just notice I'm I'm just
all about the music find someone who has
a life that you want and figure out how
they got it read books pick your role
models wisely find out what they did and
do it what would you say to all the
haters I don't think I would say
anything when I found him an M for the
first time he really changed my life
because I didn't know that music could
be intelligent like he was talking about
his own life and like he wasn't just
rhyming over music just for rhymes sake
like he was really talking about the way
that things were and so that made me
think like I could also I wouldn't rap
but I could also you know like talk
about the way that things actually were
instead of just making stupid music like
and to try and sell it um so I mean he
and also he's a he's a genius I mean
he's he's just he happens to be a genius
so I love him and then of course I love
Frank Sinatra's because for the when I
heard his voice for the first time I
couldn't believe it was real it was just
the most he has like a golden voice like
a golden tone on his voice so you know
like mm was the master of lyrics but
Frank
entre was like the master of vocals so I
really just like the Mattress from every
different genre I think one thing that
really affected me was when I was 11 I
saw Kurt Cobain singing heart-shaped box
on MTV I saw like the video for it that
was something that really struck me I
think when I was younger I knew I wanted
to be a singer but we didn't really know
anyone who was a real singer so I sort
of planned on having a more normal life
just doing something else and then when
I was 18 I moved to New York and just
started singing at the open mic nights
and playing shows down in Williamsburg
I've never been somebody who like turned
away from really hard work so like I'm
I'm always willing to put the foot work
in like with the mixing if it takes 8
months I will mix for 8 months if the
master doesn't come back right like I'll
find someone else to do it and with the
personal stuff I mean if I feel like I'm
just not getting it right like I'll just
keep on trying different things until I
feel like I'm hitting my stride I've
read a lot about you online some good
some bad have you reacted to the sort of
reaction itself to your arrival I was
reacting a lot in the beginning just cuz
no one had ever written about me before
but I sort of stopped reading it because
it was making me upset so I am pretty
busy and so I just try and focus on
writing it people are hearing your music
and you're out playing shows and people
are liking it I don't imagine that some
sniping on a hipster blog or on a
broadsheet review is part of that though
you you quite bulletproof to that
criticism do you think I don't know you
know I don't think about it too much
only because you know I've been living
in New York for about 7 years and a lot
of the people that I started singing
with don't sing anymore don't write
anymore so the fact that I can still do
that like come here play shows sing and
write you know that that's kind of a
gift that's kind of what I sort of stay
focused on like I keep writing when I
went back to New York in California the
last two weeks I got to come go back
into the studio and keep working so
I find that when I'm working I it's
easier to just sink into that the thing
I love the most about singing is that I
think when I grew up I just didn't
really connect to anything felt like
everyday life was just sort of mundane
and I was really worried that I'd never
feel connected to my profession or get
to do anything that makes me feel really
alive and just being able to sing and
and it just makes me feel like electric
and lucky to be expressing myself right
even when I'm writing for a movie or I'm
writing for somebody else's project I
sort of stayed true to my own aesthetic
which is kind of either rooted in jazz
or maybe more like a cinematic tone even
though I'm adapting lyrics for something
like this I usually have a kind of
direction that I like to stay true to
melodically when I first started making
videos I was originally collecting
vintage clips of exotic places that I
considered to be beautiful and inspiring
and started setting it to classical
music and then I eventually started
setting those clips to my own music and
slowly splicing myself in turning them
into music videos I knew in my video for
video games I wanted to feature
different clips of the chateaux because
it was one of the most beautiful places
that we had seen in Hollywood and it had
a lot of the muted blues and greens that
I was sort of inspired by for the color
scheme of my video I actually started
with the footage from here and then
started collecting my other footage for
the video based on I don't know the
energy and the colors that I found from
vintage clips of the chateaux back about
10 years ago I used a collection of
different clips some of them were some
of them were vintage clips from the 50s
and 60s of certain icons or just shots
of things that I considered to be really
beautiful and timeless and I also
spliced in different footage of more
modern clips of kids skateboarding
down in Santa Monica and also you know
like there's a modern-day actress and
that I put in the video and I feel like
all the choices I made were really they
were just personal choices I was guided
by my intuition and I just picked things
that I thought were beautiful I think
you know you just don't negotiate when
it comes to your work you just or your
art you just stand totally firm and take
the consequences I'm not a normal
performer like I do what I want like if
I feel like in a you know weird freakin
mood and I want to perform that way like
that's just what I do it doesn't matter
if it's on SNL doesn't matter if I'm an
amoeba like for an in-store record thing
like I'm not gonna chime not gonna be
like more normal just because I'm on
like a national platform sure like I
just got off a world tour around Europe
and everywhere and like you know China
like before I went on us now so it was
sort of just a continuation of what I
was already doing but they've been you
know they space any things about me no
matter what I do yeah you know it
doesn't really matter about the
performance they're just gonna like a
builds you up tear you down kind of
situation right but you know I'm in sort
of a place where reality doesn't really
you know matter like what I actually do
has nothing to do with what they say you
know or at least what they write about
very quiet life a really normal life and
I do a lot of the same things every day
when I'm home I still have my same
babysitting job I'm surprised for him
that you still babysit you tell me a
little bit about that like how is this
like a like a standing job you've had
for years how often do you babysit I
babysat twice a week when I'm here when
I'm here it's what I do but it's just
because it's something I've been doing
for a while but
I have been traveling a lot so duet how
old are the kids you babies I missed one
- it's just one don't use ten does he
know that you have this like new life um
actually yeah he's like he's very with
it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Anastasia's
stock asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson you're going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leave
it in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to Megan from the
bootstrap boutique Megan thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word doing the review in your
youtube channel and post into the
Twitter as well
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
woman Z so giving to your fans and like
well you know I I mean I've had a long
road so I get in too much you know
they might get for me you know because
you know being a nervous performer at
first I wasn't something I ever really
sought comfort in more than you know
when the show's got bigger I actually
dictated to that well of strength okay
well there's no way this person to me
I'm almost killing myself and when I
listen to your music it put me in a
place like no other I would get high I
would get drunk every night when I was
into your music the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple so it would be like a
little beacon table Ignatian if you want
to know what the most important one word
is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]